tonight on Brian Ross investigates I cry
a lot
and no one knows how much I cried she
was 14 years old when her swimming coach
began to abuse her
I lost my innocence her coach now
serving a 29 year prison sentence on Lee
the latest of almost 200 USA Swimming
Coaches implicated in a growing sex
abuse scandal that critics say the sport
continues to ignore they treat sexual
abuse as the public relations problem as
opposed to a child safety problem and
the president of USA Swimming doesn't
want to talk about it what will it take
to stop it we'll hear from Olympic gold
medalist swimmer
Nancy hogshead maker standing by in
Florida plus our shout out to the
reporter in California who helped to
expose widespread sexual abuse even as
supporters of USA Swimming denied there
was a plan they prioritized they are
protecting the brand winning a lot of
medals generating a lot of tens of
millions of dollars in corporate
sponsorship and and and not protecting
the athletes at the grassroots or at any
level from the law and crime studios in
New York City's Herald Square this is
Brian Ross investigates good evening and
welcome tonight the dark side of one of
America's most celebrated sports USA
Swimming has helped produce a steady
roster of athletes who regularly bring
home Olympic gold for America but like
USA Gymnastics the sport has also been a
place where sexual predators coaches
have abused hundreds of young athletes
and as we found out USA Swimming has
been very slow to do much about it
I feel guilty all the time I cry a lot
and no one knows how much I cried
because I bottle it up full of nails
looking she was 14 when her swimming
coats began to sexually abuse her and it
physically and mentally hurts not to cry
her coach was 43 years old at the time
Nathan weto described on the website of
the local Swim Club he owned as someone
who loves the sport of swimming and the
dedication it develops in young people
he turned me into somebody that no one
around me could recognize he groomed me
into somebody that I'm not
when the coach was brought in for
questioning by police in Raleigh North
Carolina he claimed he had no idea why
he was there
7 and 6 story
she had been swimming since I believe
about the age of six with the same coach
so he had a long time to coach her got
to know the family through that exposure
and what we now know is grooming over a
long period of time was able to gain
access to her to ultimately sexually
abused her lawyers Daniel Barker and Ian
Richardson represent the girl and her
family and they are now taking the
governing body of the sport USA Swimming
to court clay beam USA Swimming has
failed to protect their clients and
hundreds of other vulnerable young
swimmers from predators like Nathan
alleged you've got coaches who see these
people that look like grown women that
are running around and swimsuits and I
think that just invites some of the bad
behavior that we have unfortunately seen
with USA Swimming coaches well
ultimately confessed to what he had done
how's kid
I mean there are some touching up
breasts and things like that
who says
yes Oh whose core oh not hers and he
claimed he and his 14-year old swimmer
were in love with each other
we knew that we shouldn't be done and we
didn't stop I didn't stop police also
arrested Wendell's assistant swim coach
and girlfriend Shannon Foster who
authorities say knew he was sexually
abusing the young swimmer she was put on
two years probation
Raleigh's swim coach facing serious
charges accused the arrest shocked the
community
Nathan Weddell faces multiple counts of
sex crimes with an underage girl
he appeared by video and asked for a
court-appointed lawyer court documents
show this had been going on for nearly
five months for the officials who run
USA Swimming it was yet another threat
to their well cultivated public image a
multi-million dollar operations funded
by large corporate sponsors it oversees
some 3,000 swim teams around the country
pipeline for future US Olympics when
things it's all about you know keeping
mercedes-benz and the corporate sponsors
and NBC happy and the particulars of
Michael Phelps and Katie ledecky they
prioritized you know protecting the
brand winning a lot of medals and not
protecting the athletes the United
States very good
but for all the heroes and Olympic glory
of USA Swimming officials have known for
more than a decade about a very dark
side hundreds of young swimmers who were
sexually abused by their coaches cases
including one of the country's top swim
coaches Sean Hutchinson who was banned
last year after Olympic medalist Arianna
ku car went public with allegations he
had abused her organizations like USA
Swimming have long been in a position to
deter detect and discipline sexual abuse
and have done little or nothing to do
such in an effort to protect their
public image by doing nothing it enabled
Sean Hutchison to abuse me for a decade
in fact the USA Swimming website
includes a list of almost 200 coaches
who have been suspended or banned from
the sport because of allegations or
convictions for sexual abuse the list
now includes Nathan Weddell of North
Carolina the lawsuit being brought over
wells case sites at ABC News 20/20 story
that I reported nine years ago as an
example of USA Swimming failing to deal
with the problem the 20/20 story
detailed a slew of similar sexual abuse
cases and an interview with the then
president of USA Swimming Chuck why cos
who said he saw no reason to apologize
to the young victims have you apologized
to any of the young women victims you
feel I need to apologize to them why go
Slater did apologized and promised to
make things right after that report they
had told ABC News and me they were going
to clean it up has that happened it has
not happened and this continues
continues today this is nine years later
yes the lawsuit alleges that USA
Swimming failed to follow through on
recommendations from its own child
safety experts five years ago to require
mandatory training to pair
young athletes to help them spot
possible predators with what we're
called safe sport clocks how many clubs
in this state in this country we're safe
sport recognized or certified there were
no certain safe sport certified for safe
sport recognize clubs in North Carolina
had a single one not a single one I
actually looked this morning and still
can't find one within a hundred miles of
Raleigh North Carolina so what good is
this program that nobody is following it
that's a great question and nationwide
when we checked on the USA Swimming
website looking at a 100 mile radius
around the 25 largest cities we counted
only a 45 such safe sport certified
teams out of the 3,000 teams only about
one and a half percent yet in testimony
before Congress last year the current
president of USA Swimming Tim Hinchey
described the safe sport club program as
one of its major initiatives to protect
swimmers we have a number of new
initiatives underway and we are vetting
even more the safe sport recognized club
program will enhance athlete protection
efforts at all levels especially the
local level in chi declined numerous
requests from law and crime to appear in
our report when we caught up with him at
USA Swimming's annual gala fundraiser in
New York he was not very pleased to see
these are serious questions about more
more young women
in North Carolina to Congress you tell
me right now how many not certain but
why not why can't you talk because I'm
here hosting people they know these are
important questions
sir sir how many recognize safes sport
clubs Styx's today can you answer that
question sir
they treat sexual abuse as a public
relations problem as opposed to a child
safety problem we think it's a child
safety issue the lawyers say neither the
girl abused by Weddell nor her parents
ever saw or even heard about training
videos that might have alerted them to
his behavior I think if the parents had
seen that and in conjunction was seeing
it had training about what grooming
behavior looks like I think we wouldn't
be sitting here Weddell pleaded guilty
to two felony counts and is now serving
a sentence of up to 29 years in state
prison in North Carolina he says he is
sorry about what happened to the girl he
abused but it did I started with
depression and being anxious some days
are better than others for me and I wish
that none of this had ever happened
I've lost my liver swim I lost five
months of my life and I lost my
innocence we repeatedly ask USA Swimming
to respond to our questions but they
told us they did not wish to participate
in court papers the group says it has no
legal responsibility to the young women
abused by Nathan Weddell and denies any
wrongdoing next we'll talk with two
people who can help us understand what's
going on here Olympic gold medalist
Nancy hogshead Makar
an attorney Robert Allard when we come
back
we continue our investigation now into
the sexual abuse scandal involving
swimming coaches connected to USA
Swimming and we're joined now by Nancy
hogshead Makar the winner of three
Olympic swimming gold medals during the
1984 Los Angeles Olympics and founder of
champion women a route that advocates
for the protection and support of girls
and women in sport and by Robert Allard
a lawyer in San Jose who has led the way
in legal action on behalf of young
people who have been sexually abused by
their coaches thank you both for being
here
this hogshead my car let me start with
you what's going on here with the USA
Swimming why do they seem to ignore this
issue well you have to think of who is
it that evaluates how Tim hichy how the
head of USA Swimming is doing like who
gives him a salary and it's it's coaches
it's club owners so they don't really
like the idea that they're going to have
this independent entity come in and
investigate them so they're really not
that they're interested in the show but
not really interested in letting all
athletes know that the major risk of
harm to them is their coach and that's
hard
we at champion women we've come up with
a way to teach athletes even seven year
olds here's how you teach about
appropriate boundaries here's how you
teach about you know what what a coach
should a will and will not do so that
the hair on the back of their neck comes
up long before they get to the idea of
good touch bad touch Robert Alan let me
ask you this continues to be an issue
it's been an issue since we started
reporting on this with you nine ten
years ago there are more cases every day
it seems just last week we filed a
complaint locally here in near San Jose
California in Stockton where a 25 year
old swim coach for a period of eight to
nine months was having sexual
intercourse with a 13 year old and all
the while he was demonstrating very
obvious signs of predatory behavior on
the pool deck in front of all of the
club officials including putting his arm
around her hugging her stretching her
cravat
calling her babe driving her to and from
practices by himself all obvious red
flags that which anybody who was
properly trained would know was a
predator in their midst and no one did
anything about it and it resulted in
fortunately him recently being arrested
but this continues here's a question
from our controller and executive
producer Rhonda Swartz these predators
seem very good at what they do is that
really something you can blame USA
Swimming for what what really could be
done about this yeah one of the things
that somebody my are very much Scott
Reed with the Orange County Register
talked about it was that they didn't
prioritize sexual abuse I would go
further than that I would say that they
actively tried to avoid it when you look
at their legal position in court it is
we don't owe a legal duty that extends
to that kid so if somebody's abuse they
just don't think it's their problem we
just got a legislation passed last year
that was supposed to eradicate that
supposed to keep the USA Swimming and
all the national governing bodies the
United States Olympic Committee from
being able to assert that defense that
they do it gave them a legal duty to
protect kids from physical emotional and
sexual abuse Robert our let me ask you
they talked about this safe sport
program they said that's the answer but
we checked it's fewer than two percent
of the teams around the country are
certified now is safe sport they don't
make it mandatory is that a problem yeah
that's the enforcement mechanism that is
lacking they have done it might be a
very good job of putting some nice rules
on paper no one-on-one conduct contact
no skyping no social media interactions
for example but over and over again
Stockton's case as an example not only
have these people not been trained on
safe sport they have never even heard of
the program so there's an obvious
disconnect between the the creation of
the rules and the implementation of them
and when someone violates them the
enforcement mechanism is safe sport and
there are lots of problems with safe
sport this Hawks had a car when you hear
about these is the
rage still there or is it just become so
normalized oh no no no we're we're
focused on it very much so and we've got
I'm part of a broader group of people we
call ourselves the committee to restore
integrity to the United States Olympic
Committee where we we say that in order
to protect athletes you can't hire
enough people that you need to give a
fleets power if athletes had 50% of the
voting power you better believe they
would direct more resources and make
those clubs be safe sport compliant do
you think it's time for a housecleaning
at USA Swimming well certainly their
safe sport Department there already has
been a couple of house clip housekeeping
but I mean I just don't think that the
way that our athletes input of being
able to say this is really key to us
this is important to us even even
Michael Phelps is not able to shift the
budget around so that not just coaches
would know about these rules but you
need to change the culture the culture
in my era mich IV was my coach and he's
on the band list and he was actively the
same kind of thing that bob was just
talking about with his client they frame
it in terms of dating that they're
having a relationship and that somebody
else is jealous because of it instead of
looking at it this is child molestation
this is abuse this is an abuse of power
this is criminal conduct so if there's a
normalization of athletes and their
coaches having these romantic and sexual
relationships that's why you've got to
educate the parents and the
seven-year-old Robert Allen let me ask
you you dealt with these victims the
survivors and their parents what's the
advice you give to other parents who are
watching this who have children and USA
Swimming teams don't just assume that by
entrusting your child to a swim club
that they have properly vetted their
coaches and have properly supervised
them make sure that there is if it's
safe sport make sure that the safe sport
program is is implemented and
and enforced and look into your coach's
background there is not enough can be
done to look into someone's background
to make sure that they don't have any
type of predatory characteristics or
qualities do you have more cases coming
is this over I wish I could say it was
over Brian you and I did this nine years
ago and the the calls keep coming to me
over and over again and it hasn't
changed at the ground level which is
what I deal with the victims and the
parents and the clubs I'm not seeing a
change I'm seeing the same old same old
which is you have a coach who's out
there doing all sorts of things which
should be raising sirens and alarms and
nothing's done and kids are getting
molested so as long as that's happening
we're going to keep doing we're doing
all right increase awareness as much as
we can and stop this problem Robert
Allard the Nancy hogshead makar thank
you so much for joining us next our
shout out for a reporter who has led the
way on this ongoing scandal when we come
back
our shout out tonight to the reporter at
the Orange County Register in California
who is doggedly pursued the scandal of
sexual abuse at USA Swimming Orange
County is kind of epicenter of America
so I mean this so this was really in our
backyard Scott Reed calls himself a
sports investigative reporter and over
the years we've done a lot of
investigative work on sexual abuse in
USA Gymnastics so this kind of blended
into swimming and he quickly realized
USA Swimming had a lot to hide it wasn't
easy it's a very closed Network it's a
good old boys network there's a couple a
handful of people that kind of run the
sport really powerful coaches and and if
you want to move up in the sport you
know you don't want to cross but Reed
took the time to listen to survivors
young women who had been abused but who
felt that USA Swimming was covering up
what happened you asked these survivors
about what happened to them and you're
really the first person to have to
really give them give them an honest
listen and that was huge I think that
was a big part of our reporting but read
stories did not go over well with USA
Swimming and local readers who were part
of the swimming community lot of yeah a
lot pushback you know nasty emails nasty
calls reads most recent story involved
allegations brought against swim coach
Sean Hutchinson he was a World
Championship team coach in 2009 he was a
blimpy team he's on Olympic team
coaching staffs and he ran this
high-profile Olympic prospect training
group in Fort in California and there
was allocations at Hutchison was
physically involved with a swimmer he
judged by name Arianna Cukor's who was
the world champion and world record
holder and 200 I am during that decade
he stole many things from me including
my swimming career my college experience
friendships my virginity and ultimately
my Olympic dream USA Swimming
investigated it eventually cleared him
of any wrongdoing but documents Reid
obtained told a much different story
what these documents show is that the
person that was hired to investigate
this matter a woman who was a former 20
was a 27 year veteran of the
the I was told not to interview certain
people without a louder interview
certain people and so what we found
where it was a deposition and some other
documents from this investigator that
prove that this that the finding of
investigation was just totally incorrect
one more example of the power and
importance of investigative journalism
and staying on the story like that a
dictator you have to do you have to do
what's best for the reader what's best
for people be writing about you know a
newspaper has responsibilities to its
readers to sometimes tell them what they
don't want to hear so our shout out
tonight to Scott Reed at the Orange
County Register that's our report for
tonight thanks for joining us we'll see
you back here again next week good night